Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the fields of Cressy and Agincourt. The renowned King Arthur is generally looked upon as the first who ever sat down to a whole roasted ox, which was certainly the best way to preserve the gravy. And it is further added that he and his knights sat about it at his round table, and usually consumed it to the very bones, before they would enter on any debate of moment. The Black Prince was a professed lover of the brisket, not to mention the history of the sirloin, or the institution of the order of beef eaters,
感谢您收听《历史其余部分》。想要获取每周独家播客、无广告收听、剧集抢先听以及我们备受喜爱的聊天社区会员资格，请访问 therestishistory.com，加入克雷西和阿金库尔的战场。著名的亚瑟王通常被认为是第一个坐下来享用一整头烤全牛的人，这无疑是保留肉汁的最佳方式。书中还补充说，他和他的骑士们围坐在圆桌旁，通常会把牛肉吃得精光，连骨头都不剩，才会开始商讨任何重要议题。黑太子是一位公开的胸肉爱好者，更不用说牛里脊的历史，或是吃牛肉者（Beef Eaters）仪仗队的设立，
which are all so many evident and undeniable marks of the great respect which our warlike predecessors have paid to this excellent food. The tables of the ancient gentry of this nation were covered thrice a day with hot roast beef, and I am credibly informed by an antiquary who has searched the registers in which the bills of fare of the court are recorded, that instead of tea and bread and butter, which have prevailed of late years, the maids of honour in Queen Elizabeth's time were allowed three rumps of beef for their breakfast. Now that, Dominic, as you will well know, because you sent that quote to me, was Joseph Addison writing in the Tatler in 1710 about roast beef yes and today we are looking at England our own native land um and you have chosen as your
这些都成了明显且无可否认的标志，表明我们好战的先辈对这种极品食物给予了极大的尊重。这个国家古代贵族的餐桌上，一天三次摆满了热腾腾的烤牛肉。一位查阅过宫廷菜单记录的古物研究员向我可靠地透露，在伊丽莎白女王时期，宫廷里的荣誉女官们早餐吃的是三块牛臀肉，而不是近年流行起来的茶和面包黄油。多米尼克，正如你所熟知的——因为这段引言是你发给我的——那是约瑟夫·亚迪森于1710年在《闲谈者》杂志上关于烤牛肉的文字。没错，而今天我们要审视的是英格兰，我们自己的祖国，嗯，你选择的主题是
theme this great theme of roast beef and the role that it's played in notions of liberty and distinctiveness and John Bull and all that kind of stuff. Yes. Well, England, Tom, I mean, so much to choose from because, of course, we are both English. But I thought, why not choose one of the most English things of all, which is roast beef or indeed beef and liberty? That's the theme of today's podcast. Now, of course, for you, this is slightly, it's ambiguous ground, isn't it? Because while I'm sure you would style yourself a very patriotic Englishman, you are not, it's fair to, isn't it? Because while I'm sure you would style yourself a very patriotic Englishman, you are not, it's fair to say, one of life's great beef eaters.
这个伟大的主题：烤牛肉，以及它在自由观念、独特个性、约翰牛（John Bull）以及诸如此类的概念场所扮演的角色。是的。嗯，英格兰，汤姆，我的意思是，有太多的东西可以选择，因为当然，我们都是英格兰人。但我想，为什么不选择最具有英格兰特色的一样东西，那就是烤牛肉，或者确切地说，牛肉与自由呢？这就是今天播客的主题。当然，对你来说，这稍微有点，这是一个模棱两可的领域，不是吗？因为虽然我确信你会把自己塑造成一个非常爱国的英格兰人，但你并不是——这样说算公平吧？因为虽然我确信你会把自己塑造成一个非常爱国的英格兰人，但你并不是，这样说挺公平的——生活中的那些大胃王。
No, not really. As in not at all. Yeah, not at all. No. Well, I mean, listeners can draw their own conclusions about the patriotism or otherwise of Tom Holland. Well, but I love liberty. You love liberty. So beef and liberty, that's the slogan that's stamped on the buttons of the waistcoat of the members of the Beefsteak Club.
不，其实并没有。或者说完全没有。对，完全没有。不。好吧，我的意思是，听众可以对汤姆·霍兰德是否爱国得出自己的结论。不过，我热爱自由。你也热爱自由。所以“牛肉与自由”，这就是印在牛排俱乐部成员马甲纽扣上的口号。
It is indeed, and we should be coming to the Beefsteak Club. So roast beef, today roast beef, I suppose, competes with fish and chips, doesn't it? And chicken tikka masala is one of the great emblematic national dishes. We probably eat less beef per capita than at any time, I would guess, for centuries, wouldn't you say? Because there's so much suspicion of red meat now for health reasons and all this sort of stuff. And also, of course, mad cow disease, I'm sure, delivered quite a fatal blow.
确实如此，我们马上就会讲到牛排俱乐部。所以烤牛肉，今天的烤牛肉，我想，它能与炸鱼薯条相媲美，不是吗？而鸡肉玛莎拉也是标志性的国民菜肴之一。我想我们现在人均消耗的牛肉量，大概是几个世纪以来的最低谷了吧，你不觉得吗？因为出于健康原因，现在对红肉有这么多的猜疑，诸如此类的事情。当然，还有疯牛病，我确信它也带来了相当致命的打击。
I think it did deliver it a blow. But the idea of the English as beef eating, so the French, french of course call us so it's not purely our self-image it's also the way we are perceived as we call them yeah as we call them frogs and we should be coming to frogs and the contrast between frogs and roast beef in a second but the association between the the english in particular and, is an old one. So in Shakespeare's Henry V, which I think is commonly agreed to have been written in 1599, there's a scene just before the Battle of Agincourt, and the French are talking. The Constable of France and various other knights and commanders
我认为它确实带来了打击。但英格兰人吃牛肉的观念——法国人当然也这样称呼我们，所以这不仅仅是我们的自我形象，也是我们被感知的方式，正如我们称呼他们那样，是的，正如我们称呼他们为“吃青蛙的人”（frogs），我们马上就会讲到“青蛙”以及“青蛙”与烤牛肉之间的对比——这种英国人与牛肉的特殊联系，是一个古老的传统。所以在莎士比亚的《亨利五世》中——我认为人们普遍认为该剧写于1599年——在阿金库尔战役前夕有一个场景，法国人在交谈。法国统帅和各种其他骑士与指挥官
are talking. And one Frenchman says, that island of England breeds very valiant creatures. Their mastiffs are of unmatchable courage. And the constable of France says, the men do sympathize with the mastiffs in robustious and rough coming on, leaving their wits with their wives, and then give them great meals of beef and iron and steel. They will eat like wolves and fight like devils. So even there, at the end of the 16th century, you have a hint of some themes that will become very familiar in this episode. So the association of the English with beef and with mastiffs or bulldogs and with bulls and with fighting like animals and with this sort of
正在交谈。其中一个法国人说：“英格兰那个岛屿孕育了非常勇猛的生物。他们的獒犬有着无与伦比的勇气。”而法国统帅说：“那些人在勇猛粗鲁的冲锋中，与獒犬心意相通，把理智留给了妻子，然后给它们吃大量的牛肉、钢铁。它们吃起饭来像狼，打起架来像恶魔。”因此，即便在那里，在16世纪末，你也能看到一些在本集中会变得非常熟悉的题外话。因此，英国人与牛肉、与獒犬或斗牛犬、与公牛、与像动物一样战斗、以及这种
primitive animal spirits and lack of sophistication. Now, this, of course, is Shakespeare talking. It's not the French talking. And why would beef seem to matter? Well, an obvious reason, Tom, even though you don't eat beef, is that in Tudor England, a lot of people did. So obviously, people let beef all over Europe. But I think it's pretty fair to say that the Tudors eat more meat than their neighbours do. Tudor English men and women. And why is that? Well, so there's a brilliant book on this, which I should have flagged up already, actually, called Beef and Liberty by a chap called Ben Rogers.
原始的动物精神和缺乏精致感的联系。现在，这当然是莎士比亚在说话，而不是法国人在说话。为什么牛肉似乎如此重要？嗯，一个显而易见的原因，汤姆，尽管你不吃牛肉，那就是在都铎时期的英格兰，很多人都吃。显而易见，欧洲各地的人都吃牛肉。但我认为可以说，都铎王朝的人比他们的邻居吃更多的肉。都铎时期的英国男人和女人。这是为什么呢？嗯，关于这一点有一本精彩的书，其实我早该提到了，它叫《牛肉与自由》，作者是一个叫本·罗杰斯的人。
It was published about 20 years ago. An absolutely wonderful journey through this topic from which I have stolen mercilessly balance and poems and so on. And he's speaking to you, isn't it? Because the image is, well, I suppose John Bull.
它大约在20岁前出版。这是一场绝对精彩的关于这个主题的旅程，我从里面无耻地剽窃了平衡、诗歌等等。这正是为你准备的，不是吗？因为这个形象，嗯，我想就是约翰牛。
Well, we'll come to John Bull. John Bull is literally, I mean, he, he begins as a bull, doesn't he? Well,
嗯，我们会谈到约翰牛。约翰牛简直就是——我的意思是，他，他最初是一头公牛，不是吗？嗯，
I'm not sure whether he does. There is an association between the English and bulls. I think John Bull, well, we'll come to John Bull. I shall with his waistcoat. Yes, okay, I'm sorry. His pewter tankard and all this sort of stuff. But it's the embodiment of non-metropolitan.
我不确定他是不是。英国人和公牛之间确实有一种联系。我认为约翰牛——好吧，我们会谈到约翰牛的。我将穿着他的马甲。是的，好吧，我很抱歉。他手里拿着白蜡锡马克杯和诸如此类的一大堆东西。但他是非都市化的化身。
Yeah. The solid sense of the English gentleman, country gentleman, his waistcoat straining as he devours yet another haunch of beef yeah that's pretty much solid common sense exactly absolutely right um outraged of chipping norton i think it's it's not even outraged perhaps i mean no no it's pragmatic and phlegmatic yeah i mean you know hysterical overreaction that's the kind of thing that Frenchmen and Londoners get up to. Exactly. That enthusiasm of all kinds, I think, Tom, is the enemy.
对。英国乡绅身上那种踏实的作风，乡村乡绅，当他大口吞下又一块牛排时，他的马甲紧绷着——是的，那几乎就是坚如磐石的常识，绝对没错，嗯，“奇平诺顿的愤怒人士”，我想这甚至不是愤怒，也许，我的意思是，不，不，这是务实而冷静的。我的意思是，你知道，歇斯底里的过度反应，那是法国人和伦敦人干的事。正是如此。各种形式的热情，我想，汤姆，都是敌人。
Episcene. Right. I've got some great quotes coming about Londoners and their metropolitan foppish ways, which you will be delighted by. So Ben Rogers, in his book, he says there are obvious reasons why people would eat more beef. As we've talked about many times going back to our Anglo-Saxon podcasts, England is very rich in farmland compared with a lot of European countries. You know, it's got lots of lowlands, green verdant lowlands. It's perfect for dairy farming. It is producing a lot of kind of milk and butter and beef. Over the course of the
阴柔的。对的。我有一些关于伦敦人和他们大都市装腔作势的生活方式的精彩引言，你会为此感到高兴的。所以本·罗杰斯在他的书中说，人们会吃更多牛肉是有显而易见的原因的。正如我们多次探讨的那样，回到我们的盎格鲁-撒克逊播客，与许多欧洲国家相比，英格兰拥有非常丰富的农田。你知道，它有许多低地，郁郁葱葱的低地。它非常适合奶牛养殖。它出产大量的牛奶、黄油和牛肉。在
16th century, although there are general price rises, so it's a time of great inflation then as now, the price of beef falls relative to other products. So beef is much more readily available. And the one way we can tell how much people ate and how distinctive this was is from travellers' stories. So first of all, English travellers who go abroad. So Ben Rogers gives a brilliant example of a chap called Sir Richard Morrison, who goes to Venice in the 1570s. And he says he is astounded by the food. And he says there is more meat eaten in two months in London than an entire year in Venice. So he's struck. Well, not many cows in Venice. So he's struck. Well, not many cows in Venice.
16世纪的过程中，尽管物价普遍上涨——所以当时和现在一样是一个通货膨胀严重的时期——但牛肉的价格相对于其他产品而言却在下降。因此牛肉更容易买到了。而我们了解人们吃了多少以及这种饮食有多独特的一个方法，就是通过旅行者的故事。首先，是出国旅行的英国人。本·罗杰斯举了一个绝佳的例子，一个叫理查德·莫里森爵士的人，他在1570年代去过威尼斯。他说他对那里的食物感到震惊。他说威尼斯两个月里吃掉的肉，比威尼斯一整年吃掉的还要多。所以他很震惊。好吧，威尼斯没几头牛。所以他很震惊。好吧，威尼斯没几头牛。
Not many cows, exactly. But also there's an Italian traveler called Alessandro Magno who comes to London about the same time. And he writes in Italian, I assume, it's extraordinary to see the great quantity and quality of meat, beef and mutton that comes every day from the slaughterhouses in the city the beef is not expensive and they roast it whole in large pieces for those who cannot see it it's almost impossible to believe that they could eat so much meat in one city alone and as time goes on i think over the next let's
没有多少牛，确实。但同时，还有一个叫亚历山德罗·马尼托的意大利旅行者，他大约在同一时期来到伦敦。他用意大利语写道——我猜是这样的——“看到每天从城里的屠宰场运来的大量且优质的肉类、牛肉和羊肉，真是令人难以置信。牛肉并不贵，他们用大块整块地烤给那些买不起的人吃，几乎让人无法相信单单一个城市就能吃掉这么多的肉。”随着时间的推移，我想在接下来的，比方说
say 150 years beef becomes steadily cheaper relative to other meats partly because of enclosures. So farmland is becoming much more productive. So there's just more meat, more butter, more of this sort of stuff being produced. And also there's the agrarian revolution. Exactly, the agrarian revolution. So there's just a sort of sense that there's just more of it, and probably better quality. And travellers from abroad remark on it more and more as time goes on. So in 1698, a Frenchman called Henri Misson,
150年里，相对于其他肉类，牛肉变得越来越便宜，部分原因是圈地运动。因此农田变得更加高产。所以有更多的肉、更多的黄油以及诸如此类的东西被生产出来。还有农业革命。没错，农业革命。所以人们有一种感觉，就是肉变多了，而且质量可能也更好了。随着时间的推移，来自国外的旅行者对此有了越来越多的评论。因此，在1698年，一个叫亨利·米松的法国人
he says at that point, as early as 1698, it is common practice to have a huge piece of roast beef on Sundays, of which people stuff until they can swallow no more and they eat the rest cold
他说，早在1698年那个时候，星期日吃一大块烤牛肉已经成为一种普遍做法，人们会吃到再也咽不下去为止，剩下的则在接下来的六天里吃冷的。
the other six days of the week. Now, of course, he could have been writing that as late as the 1950s, but he's writing that in the 1690s. Is there a kind of an association on the part of foreign observers between the eating of beef and the sense of the English as simultaneously violent and phlegmatic, which seems to be a kind of an abiding theme?
现在，当然，他写下这话时完全可以是在20世纪50年代，但他写于17世纪90年代。外国观察家是否在吃牛肉与英国人既暴力又冷静的特质之间建立了一种联系？这种特质似乎成了一种挥之不去的主题？
No, I don't. Well, I don't think they make a direct association, but it's absolutely right that the same travellers will be making those points. So you're absolutely right that the English are perceived as being very violent, disputatious, and yet at the same time... Ponderous.
不，我不这么认为。嗯，我不认为他们建立了直接的联系，但绝对正确的是，同样的旅行者会表达这些观点。所以你绝对说得对，英国人被认为是非常暴力、好辩的，但与此同时……迟钝笨拙。
Gruff and stoical and all these sort of things. Like bulls or oxen, perhaps. Exactly. Yes, exactly. So you can sort of see why people would make that, the sort of red-bloodedness, if you like. And the converse is that presumably when the English go, say, to France and they see them all eating frogs and vegetables and onions and things,
粗鲁而坚忍，诸如此类的事情。也许就像公牛或阉牛。没错，完全是这样。所以你可以明白为什么人们会产生这种印象，如果你愿意的话，这就是所谓的充满血性。而反过来，大概当英国人去到，比方说法国，看到他们都在吃青蛙、蔬菜和洋葱之类的时候，
they think it's very poor. And I suppose the archetype of that is William Hogarth's painting. Well, we should come to Hogarth. He will play a key part. Okay, sorry. So I'm jumping the gun again. That's fine, Tom. It's good to anticipate.
他们会觉得这些东西非常寒酸。我想威廉·霍加斯的画作就是这种现象的典范。好吧，我们应该谈谈霍加斯。他在其中扮演了关键角色。好的，抱歉。所以我又操之过急了。没关系，汤姆。有预见性是好的。
Slacking it up. Okay. So the English are definitely eating an awful lot of beef. Ben Rogers calls us the Texans of the early modern world. I like that. And I think that's, for our Texan listeners, that's a comparison I welcome. If it's associated with any one class in particular, he thinks it's associated with yeoman, so yeoman farmers. So people will-
把它说透。好的。所以英国人确实在吃大量的牛肉。本·罗杰斯称我们为早期现代世界的得克萨斯人。我喜欢这个说法。我认为，对于我们的得克萨斯听众来说，这是一个我乐于接受的比较。如果它与某一个特定阶层有关的话，他认为它与自耕农有关，也就是自耕农。所以人们会——
Okay, so not the gentry. Well, the gentry will eat beef. And in fact, French, some of these travelers do remark on this. A Swiss traveler in 1726 called Monsieur Mural, he says they'll eat roast beef as well at a king's table as at a tradesman's. So there's actually an odd sense in which the eating of roast beef is, is it democratic? That's probably the wrong word, but it's universal. But also an index of wealth, presumably. Yes, although it's not that expensive. Again, the point is, it's not that expensive. So if
好吧，所以不是乡绅。嗯，乡绅也会吃牛肉。事实上，法国人，其中一些旅行者确实注意到了这一点。1726年的一位瑞士旅行者，名叫穆拉先生，他说他们在国王的桌子上吃烤牛肉，就像在店主的桌子上吃一样好。所以实际上有一种奇怪的感觉，即吃烤牛肉——这是民主的吗？这可能是个错误的词，但它是普遍存在的。而且大概也是财富的标志。是的，尽管它其实没那么贵。再说一次，重点是，它没那么贵。所以如果
you're eating stuffed quails or something, then you're rich. But presumably, it's quite expensive on the continent relative to the expense in england yes exactly i think that's absolutely right i think it's because england has that still this farmland or whatever i'm not a massive agrarian specialist it's fair to say tom um it's up there with my knowledge of portuguese sailing technology uh but because we have all this beef is readily available slaughterhouses pumping out all this stuff if slaughterhouses can i mean the stuff they're pumping out actually i don't even want to think about i think that's sausage factories yeah exactly food manufacturers but it's associated with yeoman farmers and of course the yeoman of
你吃的是塞满鹌鹑之类的东西，那你就是富人了。但大概在欧洲大陆，相对于在英格兰的开销，它算是相当昂贵的。是的，完全正确，我想这绝对是对的。我想这是因为英格兰仍然拥有那些农田，无论如何——说实话，我可不是什么庞大的农业专家，汤姆，这就像我对葡萄牙航海技术的了解一样少——但因为我们拥有这一切，牛肉随处可见，屠宰场里源源不断地生产出所有这些东西，如果屠宰场可以的话——我的意思是它们生产的东西，实际上我甚至都不想去想，我想那是香肠工厂，是的，没错，食品制造商——但它与自耕农联系在一起，当然，近卫军的自耕农
the guard are known as beef eaters of course they are yeah and um and how long does that go back how far does that go back well i think does that go back? Well, I think that goes back centuries, actually. There are various explanations about why they're called beef eaters, but Rogers points out that right up to the 19th century, if you're a yeoman of the guard, you are given a ration of beef every day. So if you're a yeoman of the guard at St. James's Palace, you are still being given 24 pounds of beef a day, which is a lot of beef. Yeah, it is. Now, here's a key thing. How do people cook it? You day, which is a lot of beef. Yeah, it is. Now, here's a key thing. How do people cook it?
被称为“牛肉食客”，当然是的，是的。而且，这可以追溯到多久以前？这可以追溯到多远？嗯，我认为这可以追溯到好几个世纪以前，实际上。关于他们为什么被称为牛肉食客，有各种各样的解释，但罗杰斯指出，一直到19世纪，如果你是近卫军的自耕农，你每天都会分到一份牛肉。因此，如果你是圣詹姆斯宫的近卫军自耕农，你每天仍然会分到24磅牛肉，这是一大堆牛肉。是的，确实如此。现在，这里有一个关键点：人们是怎么烹饪它的？你的一天，这就是一大堆牛肉。是的，确实如此。现在，这里有一个关键点：人们是怎么烹饪它的？
You might think this is a bit abstruse, but actually this comes back to this point about liberty, and we'll get to it. I'll explain why. Not with garlic. Right. If you're in Italy or in France, the way they have their meat in the early modern period is they will often fry it or braise it or stew it.
你可能会觉得这有点深奥，但实际上这回到了关于自由的那个观点，我们等一下会讲到。我会解释原因。不是加大蒜。对的。如果你在意大利或法国，他们在近代早期烹饪肉类的方式通常是煎、焖或炖。
The English like to roast it. Now, I didn't know this, actually. I find this fascinating. The word roast and rotate have the same kind of derivation. Roti. So they're basically the same word. And the way you would roast it, you've got an open fire, you put it on a spit and you rotate it initially by hand. But over time, I mean, that's very time consuming and boring. And you need a scullion. What if you don't have a scullion?
英国人喜欢烤着吃。现在，我其实并不知道这一点。我发现这太迷人了。“烤”（roast）和“旋转”（rotate）有着相同的词源。Roti。所以它们基本上是同一个词。你烤肉的方法是，生起一个明火，把它放在烤叉上，最初是用手转动它。但随着时间的推移——我的意思是，这非常耗时且无聊。你需要一个厨房杂役。如果你没有厨房杂役怎么办？
You get a dog to do it, Tom. How do you get a dog to do it? So they basically trap a dog on a treadmill. The dog revolves the spit. Wow. Beef or liberty. Yeah. Well, not liberty for dogs.
你弄一只狗来帮你，汤姆。你怎么弄一只狗来帮你？所以他们基本上把一只狗困在跑步机上。狗让烤叉旋转。哇。牛肉还是自由。嗯，对狗来说可没有自由。
No liberty for the dogs. But over time, they develop these things called meat jacks, which are mechanical, and they have weights. How do they work, Dominic? It's a complicated system of weights, Tom. I know you wouldn't understand. Weights going up and down and the thing rotating. I think that's a technical explanation.
对狗来说没有自由。但随着时间的推移，他们发明了一种叫做“肉类千斤顶”的东西，是机械的，带重物的。多米尼克，它们是怎么运作的？这是一个复杂的重物系统，汤姆。我知道你不会懂。重物上下移动，然后东西就在旋转。我想这是一个很技术的解释。
Thanks for clearing that up. So by the – Dr. Johnson, I think, grew up in a home in Litchfield with a meat jack. He talks about meat jack. Of course he would. Dr. Johnson is the physical embodiment of a beef eater. So a Finnish writer called Per Kalm, he visited in the late 18th century, and he said they have meat jacks in every house in England, which was clearly an exaggeration. But maybe they had them in every house he visited. I mean, that's perfectly plausible. So roasting meat is absolutely part of the sort of national, it's a national custom, I suppose you can say. So how do you eat it? So you've roasted it, you have it in its own juices, you have it in, that's its gravy. You do not have it with a fancy stock or a sauce, which is why Voltaire said the English have a hundred different religions, but only one sauce.
谢谢你帮我澄清这一点。因此——塞缪尔·约翰逊博士，我想，他是在利奇菲尔德的一个有肉类千斤顶的家里长大的。他谈到过肉类千斤顶。他当然会谈到。约翰逊博士是牛肉食客的肉体化身。所以一个叫佩尔·卡姆的芬兰作家，他在18世纪后期来访，他说英格兰每家每户都有肉类千斤顶，这显然是夸张了。但也许他拜访的每家每户都有。我的意思是，这完全是情理之中的。所以烤肉绝对是某种民族风俗的一部分，我想你可以这么说。那么你是怎么吃的呢？你把它烤好了，保留着它自己的原汁，那也就是它的肉汁。你不用什么花哨的高汤或酱汁，这就是为什么伏尔泰说英国人有一百种不同的宗教，却只有一种酱汁。
And this is the sauce, you see. So you don't have any fancy sauce. You have it with this gravy. You have it with condiments. So traditionally, English mustard, I don't really know why, possibly, I guess, lack of access to spices. But English mustard had always been stronger than continental. Surely that reflects our love of liberty.
这就是那种酱汁，你看。所以你没有任何花哨的酱汁。你就着这种肉汁吃。你配上调味品。所以传统上，英国芥末——我真的不知道为什么，可能，我猜是因为缺乏获取香料的途径。但英国芥末一直比欧洲大陆的芥末更浓烈。这当然反映了我们对自由的热爱。
Maybe. We're just strong people, Tom. Yeah, there's just no Frenchified nonsense about our mustard. In England, mustard was mixed with horseradish to make it stronger. And horseradish itself was mixed with vinegar. In France, they mixed it with cream, which made it more mellow, mild. Typical. But in England, people mixed it with vinegar. So these continental travelers who were tucking
也许吧。我们只是坚强的人，汤姆。是的，我们的芥末里可没有什么法兰西式的废话。在英国，芥末是与辣根混合来增加辣度的。而辣根本身又与醋混合。在法国，他们把它与奶油混合，这让它变得更温和、柔和。典型的作风。但在英国，人们把它与醋混合。所以这些大快朵颐的欧洲大陆旅行者
into their beef were kind of... Yes, exactly. Sort of sobbing with agony as they eat their horseradish and mustard. The other thing you would have it with, Tom, are you a big believer in puddings? I am. Yes. Because it's my father. What kind of puddings do you like? We never go out for a meal. And he will always say, is there any pud?
吃起他们的牛肉时，简直就是……是的，完全是。吃着辣根和芥末，痛苦得啜泣。还有一样东西你会配着吃，汤姆，你是个布丁的坚定信奉者吗？我是。是的。因为我父亲。你喜欢什么样的布丁？我们从来不出去吃饭。他总是会说，有布丁吗？
And there always is. But he would eat that after his main course. Am I right? Yes, he would. Yes. Well, you see, if you were in the 18th century, that would be very strange and outlandish behavior. You would eat your pudding alongside. and it would be a pudding. Yes, of course. So made of suet or something, or conceivably a pie.
而且总是会有。但他会在主菜之后才吃那个。我说的对吗？是的，他会这样。对的。你看，如果你在18世纪，那将是一种非常奇怪和古怪的行为。你会把布丁和主菜一起吃。而且它会是一个布丁。是的，当然。所以是用板油或类似的东西做的，或者很可能是个馅饼。
And so originally, we in England, I know we have a lot of Australian and American listeners who probably find it weird, our terminology for what they would call desserts, that we call them puddings, even when they're not a pudding. Originally, a pudding was a kind of cousin of the sausage. So it was like a sort of skin. So it's like a kidney pudding. Exactly. Ben Rogers says the closest you can come to a pudding
所以最初，我们在英格兰——我知道我们有很多澳大利亚和美国听众，他们可能会觉得奇怪，我们对他们所谓甜点的称呼，我们叫它们布丁，即使它们根本不是布丁。最初，布丁是香肠的一种表亲。所以它就像某种外皮。所以它就像肾脏布丁。没错。本·罗杰斯说，你能找到的最接近布丁的东西
is actually eating haggis. Haggis is basically a pudding. So skin stuffed with stuff. And interestingly, at this point, so early modern England, people didn't distinguish between sweet and savoury, and they'd shove the two in together. And that- So sweet meats.
其实是吃哈吉斯（haggis）。哈吉斯基本上就是一种布丁。也就是用皮塞满了各种东西。有趣的是，在这一点上，早期现代英格兰的人们并不区分甜味和咸味，他们会把这两种东西塞在一起。而这——所以叫“甜美肉食”。
Well, this explains to me something that has always puzzled me, which is if I say to you, would you like a mince pie? Yeah. It could mean- It's the sweet one. Right. Yes. A pudding with mince in it. Go and buy me some mince meat, Tom. Yeah. What would you come back with? Will you bring a mince pie yeah it's it could mean it's the sweet one or right yes a pudding with mince in it
嗯，这向我解释了一件一直让我感到困惑的事情，那就是如果我对你说，你想来一个肉末馅饼（mince pie）吗？是的。它可能意味着——它是甜的那种。对。是的。里面有肉末的布丁。去给我买点肉末（mince meat），汤姆。对。你会带什么回来？你会带肉末馅饼吗？是的，它可能意味着它是甜的，或者——对，是的。里面有肉末的布丁
go and buy me some mince meat tom yeah what would you come back with will you bring a minced meat or mince meat which is completely different and is sweet so christmas pudding is a kind of the last remnant one of the last remnants of this world is a plum pudding but people would have had puddings where they'd have shoved all kinds of stuff in them. I mean, this is an astonishing diet then. So you're having your roast beef and then you're having a meat pudding at the same time. Yeah, absolutely. I mean, no wonder we're rushing around conquering the world with all that amount of meat. And you're washing this down, not with French wines, but with ale or porter or fortified wine port.
去给我买点肉末，汤姆。对。你会带什么回来？你会带碎肉还是完全不同的、带甜味的肉末回来？所以圣诞布丁是这个世界的最后遗迹之一，也是最后的遗迹之一，是一个梅子布丁，但人们以前吃的布丁里面会塞进各种各样的东西。我的意思是，这真是一种惊人的饮食。所以你吃着烤牛肉，然后同时还在吃肉布丁。是的，绝对的。我的意思是，难怪我们带着那么多的肉到处跑去征服世界。而且你把这些冲洗下去的，不是法国葡萄酒，而是艾尔啤酒、波特啤酒或加强型葡萄酒波特酒。
Yeah. You know, from Portugal. From our oldest ally. So it's fair to say it's quite heavy yeah it's quite a heavy diet yeah i mean gout must be a constant risk well this is i mean who is it who was a three bottle man was it william pitt the younger yeah we were talking about in our prime minister's podcast so three bottles puddings beef i mean it's a great diet it's amazing that people live beyond the age of 40 and again am i i hope i'm not jumping the gun it's a great diet it's amazing that people live beyond the age of
是的。你知道，来自葡萄牙。来自我们最古老的盟友。所以公平地说，这相当沉重——是的，这是一种相当沉重的饮食——我的意思是，痛风一定是一个持续的风险。嗯，这就是——我的意思是，谁是那个“三瓶男”？是小威廉·皮特吗？是的，我们在首相播客里谈到过。所以三瓶酒、布丁、肉饼——我的意思是，这是一种很棒的饮食，真让人惊奇，人们竟然能活到40岁以上。而且，我是不是——希望我没有操之过急。这是一种很棒的饮食，真让人惊奇，人们竟然能活到
40 and again am i i hope i'm not jumping the gun there's a famous gilray cartoon isn't there of a weedy thin frenchman gnawing on an onion exactly yes a massively fat englishman with gout and bright red nose yeah slot with tucking into an entire roast haunch of roast beef and gravy dribbling down his waistcoat that's exactly right tom and you're not jumping the gun at all so what the french are doing is really important in this story hence the beef and liberty so the french cooking is very different so what's happened by the 18th century is that french cooking has evolved from the court it's very top down and as you would expect in a kind of absolutist court, sophistication and order
40岁以上。而且，我是不是——希望我没有操之过急。有一幅著名的吉尔雷（Gilray）漫画，不是吗？画的是一个瘦骨嶙峋的法国人在啃一个洋葱，对的，还有一个体形极其肥胖、患有痛风且鼻头发红的英国人——是的，正大快朵颐地吃着整块烤牛肉，肉汁顺着他的马甲往下流。完全正确，汤姆，你一点也没有操之过急。所以法国人在这个故事里所做的事情真的很重要，因此才有了“牛肉与自由”。所以法国烹饪非常不同。因此，到了18世纪，法国烹饪已经从宫廷演变而来，它是非常自上而下的，正如你所预料的那样，在一个某种专制宫廷中，精美和秩序
rather than simplicity is the sort of watchword. And so by the 18th century, you have the birth of something called, would you believe, Nouvelle Cuisine. So this is where the expression Nouvelle Cuisine comes from. The Nouvelle Cuisine of the 70s and 80s, kind of tiny portions, is merely the latest iteration of this so it's the french who divide sweet and savory into different courses which we wouldn't have done in britain uh it's the french who say vegetables are actually worthwhile and you could um you can cook them and fry them up or whatever or put them in a sauce it's also the french who have soups rather than broths and the french who have so what's the difference between a soup and a broth?
而不是简单，成为了某种口号。因此，到了18世纪，你看到了某种东西的诞生——你敢相信吗——叫做“新潮烹饪”（Nouvelle Cuisine）。所以这就是“新潮烹饪”这个词的来源。70年代和80年代的新潮烹饪，那种极小的分量，仅仅是这种风格的最新迭代。所以正是法国人将甜味和咸味分成了不同的菜式，而我们在英国是不会这么做的；正是法国人说蔬菜实际上是值得吃的，你可以把它做好、炒熟或者随便怎么弄，或者把它放进酱汁里；也是法国人有了汤（soups）而不是清汤（broths），并且是法国人拥有了——那么汤和清汤有什么区别呢？
Well, a soup will be creamy and based on a stock. It'll be smooth and creamy and there'll be lots of stock. Basically, it's not like a broth where you'll just shove a load of stuff into some water. And let it all... Yeah. Yeah. And crucially, they will serve their meat very differently. So they will stuff it, they will often stew it in stock,
嗯，汤会比较浓郁，以高汤为基础。它会顺滑浓郁，而且有很多高汤。基本上，它不像清汤那样，你只是把一堆东西扔进水里。然后让它们全部……对。对。而且至关重要的是，他们供应肉类的方式非常不同。所以他们会把肉塞满东西，他们经常会在高汤中炖肉，
and then they'll serve it with a special rich sauce. And this is why if you go through 18th century English culture, novels and whatnot, you will see all the time the dreaded words ragout and fricassee, which are regarded with absolute scorn and contempt. So French cookbooks of the 18th century will say, here's a recipe for a lovely ragout. This is very much a la mode. So funnily enough, even though we think of French cooking now as very conservative, in the 18th century, of course, it's very forward-looking. English cookbooks at the
然后配上特制的浓郁酱汁。这就是为什么如果你通读18世纪的英国文化、小说之类的内容，你会一直看到那些可怕的词——肉丁浓汤（ragout）和法式肉块（fricassee），人们对它们抱有绝对的蔑视和鄙视。所以18世纪的法国烹饪书会说：“这是一个美味肉丁浓汤的菜谱。这非常时髦（a la mode）。”说来也怪，尽管我们现在认为法国烹饪非常保守，但在18世纪，它当然是非常具有前瞻性的。英国的烹饪书在
same time will say, there's nothing fashionable in this book. This is traditional, old-fashioned. Unless it's being, you know, Holland House and similar Whiggish strongholds. Tom, have you been secretly reading up on this? No, but I- These are great insights. These are very good insights. Thank you. It is worth doing this podcast with you.
同一时期会说：“这本书里没有什么时髦的东西。这是传统的、老派的。”除非它是——你知道的，霍兰德庄园（Holland House）和类似的辉格党大本营。汤姆，你难道一直在秘密研读这些吗？不，但——这些都是深刻的见解。这些是非常好的见解。谢谢。跟你一起做这个播客很值得。
You do, you have great historical instincts. Thank you very much. I may not know where Uruk-I is, but- Yes, exactly. Well, as we discovered- I know what they ate at Holland House. Exactly. The aptly named Holland House
你确实，你有着极佳的历史直觉。非常感谢。我可能不知道乌鲁克-海在哪里，但——是的，完全正确。正如我们所发现的——我知道他们在霍兰德庄园吃什么。没错，恰如其名的地方叫霍兰德庄园，
where people are eating metropolitan fancy foods. So yes, the key thing is that the French have their way, the English have theirs, but the French way is making great inroads in the course of the 18th century. So in 1747, a guy called Robert Campbell writes a book called The London Tradesman, advising people about apprenticeships. And in the course of this, he goes off on a massive rant in which he says, in the days of good Queen Elizabeth, so harking back as in that quotation from the Tatler at the beginning that you started with, to this idea, this fantasy that under good Queen Bess, Protestant England, everybody ate beef six times a day or whatever. He says,
在那里人们吃着大都市的花哨食物。所以是的，关键在于，法国人有他们的方法，英国人有他们的方法，但法国人的方法在18世纪的过程中取得了巨大的进展。因此，在1747年，一个叫罗伯特·坎贝尔的人写了一本名为《伦敦商人》的书，就学徒期向人们提出建议。在此过程中，他发表了一篇长篇大论，其中说道：“在好女王伊丽莎白时代”——正如你开始时引用的《闲谈者》中的那句话一样，追溯到这种观念，即在贝斯女王的统治下，新教英格兰，每个人一天吃六次牛肉或诸如此类。他说，
in the days of good Queen Elizabeth, when mighty roast beef was the Englishman's food, our cookery was plain as plain and simple as our manners. It was not then a science or mystery and required no conjuration. But he says, we have of late years refined ourself out of that simple taste and conformed our palates to meats and drinks, dressed after the French fashion. The natural taste of fish or flesh has become nauseous
“在好女王伊丽莎白时代，当强盛的烤牛肉是英国人的食物时，我们的烹饪和我们的礼仪一样朴素而简单。它当时不是一门科学或神秘事物，不需要任何魔法。”但他说：“近年来，我们把这种简单的口味精致化了，使我们的味蕾适应了按照法国时尚烹制的肉类和饮料。鱼或肉的天然味道已经变得令人作呕，
to our fashionable stomach. We abhor that anything should appear at our tables and its native properties. He says all this new-fangled French food is dressed in masquerades, seasoned with slow poisons, and every dish pregnant with nothing. Sounds quite Daily Mail. I was going to say, it's like one of Giles Corran's Sunday Times restaurant reviews. I'd like him to end one of his reviews if he's listening. Every dish was pregnant with nothing. But why is he having this rant? Well, it is precise, as you say, because people,
让我们这些时髦的胃难以接受。我们厌恶任何带有其原本特性的东西出现在我们的餐桌上。”他说，所有这些时髦的法国食物都是经过伪装的，用慢性的毒药调味，每道菜里都孕育着虚无。听起来很像《每日邮报》。我正要说呢，这就像吉尔斯·科兰（Giles Corran）在《星期日泰晤士报》上的餐馆评论一样。如果他在听的话，我希望他能以这句话结束他的某篇评论：每道菜里都孕育着虚无。但为什么他要发飙呢？嗯，这正如你所说的那样准确，因为人们——
they're aptly named Holland House, are eating a lot of French food. So Ramonas. Right. In the course of the 18th century, there is a kind of transformation of manners. We really should do more podcasts about the 18th century. We're going to, aren't we? It's such an interesting time. We're going to. So people are adopting China and glassware and cotton and tea and coffee and all these things. And there's this kind of european it's perceived europeanization of english customs and this has a a distinct political meaning because as you said it's associated with the wig grandees with robert
恰如其名地叫霍兰德庄园的地方，正在吃大量的法国食物。所以——雷蒙娜斯。对。在18世纪的过程中，礼仪发生了一种转变。我们真的应该多做一些关于18世纪的播客。我们要做的，不是吗？那是一个非常有趣的时代。我们要做的。所以人们正在接受中国瓷器、玻璃器皿、棉花、茶、咖啡和所有这些东西。而且存在着一种欧洲化——被人们感知到的英国习俗的欧洲化——这具有一种鲜明的政治意义，因为正如你所说，它与辉格党显贵们有关，与罗伯特·沃尔波尔有关，
ballpole and in particular with the pelham family who basically succeed him and dominate british politics in the 1740s and 1750s thomas and henry pelham so thomas pelham who's the duke of newcastle who's our fourth prime minister, colossally, unbelievably rich and associated with this sort of Whig world of all these mercantile links and travel and diplomacy and sort of sense of cosmopolitanism, I suppose. But also not necessarily sound
特别是与佩勒姆家族有关，他们基本上继承了沃尔波尔的衣钵，并在1740年代和1750年代主导了英国政治，托马斯和亨利·佩勒姆——托马斯·佩勒姆是纽卡斯尔公爵，他是我们的第四任首相，极其、难以置信地富有，并且与这种辉格党的世界联系在一起，充满了各种商业联系、旅行、外交以及某种程度上对大都会主义的感觉，我想是的。但也未必在英国自由的根本问题上表现稳健。是这样吗？我认为有一种轻微的看法认为辉格党人很糟糕。我的意思是，在18世纪中期，这些类别是如此模糊。我的意思是，它们已经不同于18世纪初期的样子了。但我认为有一种腐败的感觉，觉得与这个国家广泛的基层和平民失去了联系。
on the fundamentals of British liberty. Is that right? I think there's a slight perception that the Whigs are bad. I mean, the categories are so slippery in the mid-18th century. I mean, they've changed from what they were in the early 18th century. But I think there's a sort of sense of corruption, of having lost touch with this kind of broad base of the country and the common man.
到了法国大革命背景下霍兰德庄园的全盛时期，他们基本上会欢迎雅各宾派。他们是世界公民。在特拉法加广场建立断头台以及诸如此类的事情。我不知道早期是不是这样，但毫无疑问，他们与托利党人联系在一起，托利党人会把他们与贪婪、腐败、奢侈联系在一起。
By the time of the heyday of Holland House in the backdrop of the French Revolution, they would basically welcome Jacobin. They are citizens of the world. To set up a guillotine in Trafalgar Square and all that kind of stuff. I don't know whether that's true earlier on, but definitely they're associated with the Tories, will associate them with greed and corruption, with luxury.
并且与伦敦金融城有关。是的，与金融城，与欧洲大陆主义有关。而金融城——你这么说很有意思。本·罗杰斯在他的书中说，有时候18世纪看起来就像是一场漫长的道德恐慌。一场漫长的哀号，甚至尽管英格兰在18世纪实际上做得非常好，但对于外国习俗，却有着长篇大论的歇斯底里的哀号。所以有一个牧师，他有一句很好的引言——来自约翰·布朗，他攻击他所谓的伦敦的“城镇柔弱感”，罗杰斯说，对大多数乡村绅士来说——那就是我——首都就像是一个恶性的增生，一个让朝臣和官僚、皮条客和花花公子、
And with the city. Yeah, with the city, with continentalism. And the city is interesting you say that. So in his book, Ben Rogers says basically it sometimes seems like the 18th century is one long moral panic. One long sort of howl, even though England is actually doing so well in the 18th century the one long howl of hysteria about foreign ways so there's a preacher he's got a lovely quote from um um john brown who attacks what he calls the town effeminacy of uh of london and rogers says to most rural gentlemen that's me the capital was a malignant growth a place where courtiers and placemen pimps and fops
糕点师和理发师联合起来吸干国家财富的地方。我确实想到了你，汤姆。是吗？因为他说，18世纪中期托利党人想象中的关键人物是贵族花花公子或纨绔子弟，一个势利的小碎步走路的家伙，像法国肉酱一样光滑而浓郁。是的，每当我看到法国肉酱时。是的，好吧。每当我看到法国肉酱，汤姆，我就会想到你。所以烹饪成了这个可怕的战场。你引了《闲谈者》的那句话。那是1710年。所以它发生得很早，而且贯穿了整个
pastry cooks and hairdressers united to drain the country of its wealth and i did think of you tom did you because he says the key figure in the tory imagination of the mid-18th century is the aristocratic fop or bow a snobbish mincing thing as smooth and rich as a french pate yeah well whenever i see a french pate. Yeah, well. Whenever I see a French pate, Tom, I think of you. So cookery becomes this terrific battleground. And you did the quote from the Tatler. That's 1710. So it's happening quite early on, and it runs all the way
18世纪。为了给这半场播客做个小结，你在烹饪书中也能看到这一点。18世纪最著名的烹饪书是汉娜·格拉斯（Hannah Glass）的烹饪书《烹饪艺术：简单易懂》，出版于1747年。我们——我想我们在播客里讨论过这一点，就在《历史其余部分》刚开始的时候，和佩恩·沃格勒一起，还记得吗，汤姆？饮食史。而汉娜·格拉斯的书出版时，距离“四五事件”仅仅几年时间。
through the 18th century. Just to kind of close this half of the podcast, you see this in cookbooks. And the most famous cookbook of the 18th century is hannah glass's cookbook the art of cookery made plain and easy which was published in 1747 we i think we talked about this a little bit in the podcast we did right at the beginning of the rest is history with pen vogler remember that tom history of food yeah and um hannah glass's book is published it's only just a couple of years after the 45.
所以法国人在“四五事件”中表现得非常糟糕，某种程度上默认支持小王子查理之流。而且，我想奥地利王位继承战争也已经开始了。所以我们在跟法国人打仗。基本上我们在18世纪总是在跟法国人打仗，不是吗？汉娜·格拉斯在这本书里说——我的意思是，书名本身就说明了一切：《烹饪艺术：简单易懂》。这体现了这种精神。她说，不要用法国酱汁。不要模仿法国食物。它太油腻了。它太贵了。它对你不好。它是不爱国的，诸如此类的事情。但她知道法兰西风气正在渗入这个国家，因为她说：“这个时代的盲目愚蠢是如此之深，以至于他们宁愿被一个法国傻瓜强加于人，也不愿鼓励一个
So the French have behaved very badly in the 45, kind of tacitly supporting Bonnie, Prince Charlie and whatnot. It's also, I think the War of the Austrian Succession has started. So we're fighting the French. We're basically always fighting the French, aren't we, in the 18th century. And Hannah Glass says in this book, I mean, the title itself tells you, cookery made plain and easy. That speaks of this ethos. She says, don't use French sauces. Don't copy French food. It's too rich. It's too expensive. It's bad for you. It's unpatriotic, all this sort of stuff. But she knows that Frenchness is kind of seeping into the country because she says so much is the blind folly of this age that they would rather be imposed upon by a french booby and give encouragement to a
优秀的英国厨师。”嗯，我认为这是一个非常激动人心且充满爱国主义情怀的音符，以此来结束我们的第一道菜——由牛肉组成的第一道菜。如果你回来收听第二半场，我们将发现第二道菜端上来了什么。我猜它可能还是牛肉。我看到你还在要求更多的牛肉。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、八卦猛料的固定栏目，在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家播客和现场门票的抢先购买权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到我们烤牛肉大餐的第二道菜。正如承诺的那样，多米尼克，你给我们带来了更多的牛肉吗？
good english cook well i think that's a very stirring and patriotic note on which to end our first course which has consisted of beef uh if you come back for the second half we'll find out what's what's being served up in the second course i suspect it may be beef i see you saying for more beef i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to the second course of our serving of roast beef. And as promised, Dominic, have you got more beef for us?
除了牛肉什么都没有。美国有一句俗语，不是吗？牛肉在哪里？它在这里。它就在这里。这正是它所在的地方。那么是什么将这一切变成了一种全国性的十字军东征呢？“牛肉与自由”究竟从何而来？
It's nothing but beef. There's an American phrase, isn't there? Where's the beef? It's here. It's here. That's exactly where it is. So what turns this into a kind of national crusade? Where does Beef and Liberty comes from?
嗯，汤姆，我知道有一两位演员在听这个播客。例如，演员塞缪尔·韦斯特有时会在推特上联系我们。我想说，他可不是那种会在青年保守党集会上发表演讲的人。不是这样的吗，汤姆？但他演过兽医，不是吗？是吗？是的。所以他绝对会全力支持牛肉。
Well, Tom, I know that we have one or two actors who listen to this podcast. For example, the actor Samuel West sometimes contacts us on Twitter. I think it's fair to say he's not a man who's likely to address a benefit of the young conservatives. Isn't that true, Tom? But he plays vets, doesn't he? Does he? Yes. So he'd be very much all over beef.
好吧，他会举手的。他会举手的。不管怎样，听着，出人意料的是，这个故事的英雄、爱国烹饪的捍卫者，竟然是演员和艺术家。所以这绝对不是你会想到去反对欧洲大陆精致生活的那类人。布莱恩·布莱斯德，你可以想象一下。是的。
Well, he'd have his hand up. He would. Anyway, listen, surprisingly, the heroes of this story, the champions of patriotic cookery, are actors and artists. So very much not the people you would think of to be standing against the sophistication of the continent. Brian Blessed, you could imagine. Yeah.
牛肉。布莱恩·布莱斯德是这么做的吗？是的。所以我想你已经失去了我们所有的国际观众。哦，他们看过《飞侠哥顿》。哥顿还活着！——这就是他说话的方式。
Beef. Was that how Brian Blessed, you could imagine. Yeah. Boof. Was that how Brian Blessed would do it? Yes. So I think you've lost all our international audience. Oh, they've seen Flash Gordon. Gordon's alive. Boof. That's how he talks.
牛肉。你能想象布赖恩·布莱西德会这么做吗？对。布夫。布赖恩·布莱西德会这么做吗？是的。所以我觉得我们已经失去了所有的国际观众。哦，他们看过《飞侠哥顿》。“哥顿活了！”布夫。他就是这么说话的。
Brilliant. This is top historical analysis. So actors have been very concerned about foreign influence all through the 18th century because something terrible has happened in 1710. Do you know what that is, Dom? No. It's the arrival of opera. Oh God. Yes. So the Spectator and the Tatler, these two landmark journals, which had been founded by Joseph Addison and Richard Steele, I think it is, which were great sort of advocates of beef. They had been campaigning very vigorously against the opera.
太棒了。这是顶级的历史分析。所以，在整个18世纪，演员们一直非常关注外国的影响，因为在1710年发生了一件可怕的事情。多姆，你知道那是什么吗？不知道。那是歌剧的传入。哦，天哪。是的。《旁观者》和《闲话报》这两份里程碑式的期刊，由约瑟夫·艾迪生和理查德·斯蒂尔（我想是他们）创立的，它们是牛肉的坚定拥护者。它们一直在非常积极地反对歌剧。
They had demanded a return to manly entertainments. So what is a manly entertainment? An old-fashioned English play. Torturing bulls? No. Killing dogs? Cock fighting? Killing rat?
它们要求回归男人的娱乐。那么，什么是男人的娱乐？老式的英国戏剧。虐待公牛？不对。杀死狗？斗鸡？杀死老鼠？
Ratting? Who needs opera you wouldn't see that on the stage though would you you wouldn't watch a rat being tortured on the stage
捕鼠？谁需要歌剧，你又不会在舞台上看到那种表演，对吧？你不会在舞台上看着老鼠被虐待的。
no probably not I'm going to campaign for that in my column the arts column yeah bring back
不，大概不会。我打算在我的专栏里为这个进行宣传，艺术专栏，是的，把……带回来。
cockfighting yeah brilliant that'll go down well in middle England. Anyway, listen, Jonathan Swift was also an opponent of Upridge. You know what he said about it, Tom? What did he say?
斗鸡，太棒了，这在中部英格兰会很受欢迎。不管怎样，听着，乔纳森·斯威夫特也是乌普里奇的反对者。你知道他对它怎么看吗，汤姆？他说什么了？
He said it was wholly unsuitable to our northern climate. Why? He said it was unnatural. Would you believe? Well, it's not natural, is it? It's not natural. I mean, no one could claim it's natural. But that's the point.
他说这完全不适合我们北方的气候。为什么？他说这很不自然。你敢相信吗？嗯，这确实不自然，对吧？很不自然。我是说，没有人会说这是自然的。但这就是重点。
Well, I know that's the point. Anyway. That's the whole genius of it. There was a great movement in the theatre to resist this. And we, a year ago, did a podcast about Anglo-Italian relations. We were talking about macaronis. Yes, we did. And the resistance to macaronis.
嗯，我知道这就是重点。总之。这正是它的精妙之处。剧院里曾有过一场伟大的抵触运动。一年前，我们做过一期关于英意关系的播客。我们当时在谈论“马卡罗尼”花花公子。是的，我们说过。以及对“马卡罗尼”的抵触。
And this is actually part of that whole spectrum. So the idea of sort of foreign cookery, foreign music, foreign fashion, all being wrapped up together in a great ragu. Yeah. So the real person who sort of drives this is a great friend of the rest is history. It is top investigator, novelist. Oh, brilliant. Ghost hunter.
这其实也是整个现象的一部分。所以，外国烹饪、外国音乐、外国时尚，所有这些都被包裹在一个巨大的大杂烩里。是的。所以真正推动这一切的幕后推手，是《历史的其余部分》的挚友。他是顶级调查记者、小说家。哦，太棒了。捉鬼敢死队。
And ghost hunter, Henry Fielding. So Henry Fielding writes an attack on Walpole in the 1730s called The Grub Street Opera. Important to stress, it's not really an opera. It's more a musical, an old-fashioned, good, traditional English musical. And he has a cook who sings a song in the musical. She says she hates French ways and French politeness.
还有捉鬼敢死队成员亨利·菲尔丁。因此，亨利·菲尔丁在18世纪30年代写了一部抨击沃波尔的作品，名叫《格鲁街歌剧》。需要强调的是，它其实并不是一部歌剧。它更像是一部音乐剧，一部古老、优秀、传统的英国音乐剧。他在音乐剧中安排了一个厨师唱了一首歌。她说她讨厌法国的习俗和法国的礼貌。
And she sings this song, which I shall not sing, but I shall read it to you. When mighty roast beef was the Englishman's food, it ennobled our veins and enriched our blood. Our soldiers were brave and our courtiers were good. Oh, the roast beef of old England and old English roast beef. But since we have learnt from all vapour in France to eat their ragouts as well as to dance,
她唱了这首歌，我不会唱，但我读给你们听。当强壮的烤牛肉是英国人的食物时，它纯化了我们的静脉，丰富了我们的血液。我们的士兵勇敢，我们的朝臣优秀。哦，老英格兰的烤牛肉，还有老英格兰的烤牛肉。但自从我们学会了像法国的蒸汽一样，吃他们的肉酱也学跳舞，
oh, what a fine figure we make in romance. Oh, the roast beef of old England and old English roast beef. Then Britons, from all nice dainties refrain, which effeminate Italy, France and Spain, and mighty roast beef shall command on the main. Oh, the roast beef of old England, and old English roast beef. It would have been lovely to hear that being sung on the terraces, wouldn't it? It would. I'd love to see that.
哦，我们在传奇故事里显得多么滑稽。哦，老英格兰的烤牛肉，还有老英格兰的烤牛肉。那么不列颠人啊，远离那些娇嫩的美味吧，它们属于柔弱的意大利、法国和西班牙，伟大的烤牛肉将在大洋上发号施令。哦，老英格兰的烤牛肉，还有老英格兰的烤牛肉。听到这首歌在看台上被唱响一定很美妙，对吧？确实会。我很想看看。
Well, if you are interested. So that play was actually never performed. It was suppressed. But Fielding later reused it in another play, and he gave it to his friend Richard Leverage, who was a kind of playwright and songwriter, and he found a catchier tune for it. And by about the middle of the 18th century,
好吧，如果你感兴趣的话。所以这部剧其实从未上演过。它被禁了。但菲尔丁后来在另一部剧中重新使用了它，他把它交给了他的朋友理查德·莱弗奇，他算是一位剧作家和词曲作家，他为这首歌找到了一个更抓耳的曲调。到了18世纪中叶左右，
there was a fashion for audiences to sing it before and after other plays. So you went to the theatre to see some other play, and everyone's singing about roast beef. But presumably not before operas. Well, no, I think a very different audience. Yeah, different crowd. I think there, you're there with the Duke of Newcastle, and you're looking forward to his French cook serving you up some dainties.
观众中流行在其他戏剧上演的前后演唱这首歌。所以你去剧院看别的戏，结果所有人都在唱烤牛肉。但大概不在歌剧上演前吧？嗯，不，我觉得那是完全不同的观众。是的，不同的群体。我想在那里，你和纽卡斯尔公爵坐在一起，期待着他的法国厨师为你端上一些精美小菜。
Yes. So you're not part of the roast beef crowd. But, Tom, if you really want to sing that, do you know where it will be sung? At a formal mess dinner of His Majesty's Royal Navy today. Wow. They have the roast beef of Old England. The Royal Artillery at their dinners, at formal dinners of the United States Marine Corps. Goodness.
是的。所以你不是烤牛肉狂热粉那一挂的。但是，汤姆，如果你真的很想唱那首歌，你知道它会在哪里被唱起吗？今天在英国皇家海军的正式军官食堂里。哇。他们有《老英格兰的烤牛肉》。还有英国皇家炮兵队的晚宴上，美国海军陆战队的正式晚宴上。天哪。
And of the Canadian Armed Forces. They sing the roast beef of England, of old England. They use the tune. I don't think they do the words. I was going to say, that would be odd, wouldn't it? I think they're maybe piped into the dinner or something. So it's basically the tune and the sort of the the ethos i suppose it has endured across the world in armed forces that were once related to to to britain basically
以及加拿大军队。他们唱《英格兰的烤牛肉，老英格兰的》。他们用的是这个曲调。我想他们不用歌词。我刚想说，那会很奇怪，对吧？我想也许是通过广播把曲子放进餐厅什么的。所以基本上就是曲调和那种精神内核，我想它在那些曾经与英国有关联的武装部队中一直流传到今天。
so and this is the name of the famous painting the hogarth paints the hogarth painting which we should come to because hogarth is a member of a club so what the actors do so people like people who are associated with fielding, people of that kind of disposition, they start to set up from about 1705 beefsteak clubs. The first one was associated with the Drury Lane Theatre. There was an actor called Richard Escort, who was kind of the master of ceremonies. And he wore a little badge with a kind of gold gridiron or grill around his neck to show his fondness for roast beef. And the most famous one of these was set up in 1735 called the Sublime Society of Beef Steaks.
所以，这也是那幅著名画作的名字，霍加斯画的，我们应该谈谈霍加斯的那幅画，因为霍加斯是一个俱乐部的成员。演员们是怎么做的呢？所以像菲尔丁身边的人、那种性格的人，从1705年左右开始建立牛肉俱乐部。第一个俱乐部与德鲁里巷剧院有关。有一个叫理查德·埃斯科特的演员，他算是典礼官。他脖子上戴着一个小徽章，上面有一个金色的烤架或烤盘图案，以显示他对烤牛肉的喜爱。其中最有名的一个成立于1735年，叫做“崇高牛肉俱乐部”。
So you mentioned Hogarth. Hogarth was a member, the great British painter and engraver. John Wilkes, the sort of radical gadfly, parliamentary gadfly. He was a member. Dr. Johnson was a member. Another associate of the show, future fat king, George IV. He was also a member. And they would meet above the Covent Garden Theatre.
所以你提到了霍加斯。霍加斯是会员，这位伟大的英国画家和版画家。约翰·威尔克斯，那种激进的牛虻，议会里的牛虻。他是会员。约翰逊博士是会员。节目的另一个常客，未来的胖国王乔治四世。他也是会员。他们会在科芬园剧院楼上聚会。
They would wear a special blue coat. You said about their waistcoat, special waistcoat with brass buttons that said, had Beef and Liberty written on, they were a badge um a sort of silver medal of the gridiron and again beef and liberty so there you have the association between liberty which is a great watchword against catholic france and beef eating and obviously what you would eat if you're a vegetarian this was i mean tom you would not be welcome at this club. You had to go and you had to eat beef, mustard, and horseradish, and baked potatoes, interestingly.
他们会穿一件特别的蓝色外套。你刚才说他们的背心，带有黄铜纽扣的特殊背心，上面写着“牛肉与自由”，他们佩戴一个徽章，一种银质的烤架奖章，上面同样写着“牛肉与自由”。所以这里你就能看到自由——这是对抗天主教法国的重要口号——与吃牛肉之间的联系。显然，如果你是个素食主义者，汤姆，你在这个俱乐部里是绝对不受欢迎的。你得去吃牛肉、芥末、辣根，还有烤土豆，有趣的是。
They would have it with baked potatoes. Not chips? I don't think there's any chips. No. The Beefsteak Club lasted for about another 130 years. It was wound up in 1867, by which time the idea of beefsteak clubs is incredibly unfashionable. But we mentioned Hogarth.
他们会配烤土豆吃。没有薯条吗？我想没有什么薯条。没有。牛肉俱乐部又持续了大约130年。它于1867年解散，到那时，牛肉俱乐部的概念已经变得极其不合时宜。但我们提到了霍加斯。
You could argue that beef is personal for Hogarth because he'd grown up in a Smithfield market. Yeah, he's baptised in St. Bartholomew the Great. So there you go. We saw it. So for people who don't know, his career flourishes between the 1730s and the 1750s. I always think, I mean, Tom, I know you love
你可能会说牛肉对霍加斯来说具有个人意义，因为他在史密斯菲尔德市场长大的。是的，他在圣巴塞olomew the Great受洗。所以你看。我们看到了。所以对于不了解的人来说，他的职业生涯在18世纪30年代到1750年代之间蓬勃发展。我一直觉得，汤姆，我知道你喜欢……
Dickens. Do you think Hogarth is a bit of a forerunner of Dickens, the same kind of character and colour and love of London? He's a kind of Dr. Johnson as a pitbull, I guess would be the way to describe him. He's more spiky than Dr. Johnson, isn't he? Yeah, he is. He is. There's a kind of aggression to Hogarth and a sort of slight element of misanthropy, would you say? Yeah, I think so to a degree. Yes. If he was a political cartoonist, I think it's fair to say he'd probably be writing,
狄更斯。你觉得霍加斯有点像狄更斯的先驱吗，有着同样的角色、色彩和对伦敦的热爱？我想他大概可以被形容为一只斗牛犬式的约翰逊博士。他比约翰逊博士更带刺，对吧？是的，他是。他是。霍加斯身上有一种侵略性，还有一点轻微的厌世情绪，你会这么觉得吗？是的，某种程度上是的。是的。如果他是个政治漫画家，我觉得可以公平地说，他可能会为那些更野蛮的报纸工作。
he'd be doing his work for one of the more feral newspapers. Yeah. So you mentioned him doing the roast beef of Old England. So the original painting was called The Gate of Calaisais and he'd actually been arrested as a spy in calais while sketching it and he shows himself doesn't he in the painting yes doing a sketch exactly and he'd actually shown sketches to the french to say look i am actually a painter i'm not here spying and you can look it up online um you can google it basically the scene is at the gate of calais and it shows a huge side of beef being transported from the harbour
是的。所以你提到他创作了《老英格兰的烤牛肉》。所以最初的画作叫做《加来之门》，他在加来素描时实际上被当作间谍逮捕了，他在画中画了自己正在素描，对吧？是的，确实在画画。他实际上把素描拿给法国人看，说“看，我其实是个画家，我不是来这里当间谍的”，你们可以在网上查到，嗯，你们可以谷歌一下。基本上场景是在加来之门，画面显示一大块牛肉正从海港运送到一家英国人开的小酒馆里，而一群衣衫褴褛、骨瘦如柴、面目阴险的法国士兵和一个非常胖的法国天主教修士正看着这块牛肉。他们流着口水，你知道的，充满了嫉妒。这被制作成了一幅畅销版画，并更名为《哦，老英格兰的烤牛肉》。牛肉俱乐部的一位朋友，一个叫西奥多西厄斯·福雷斯特的家伙，他写了牛肉俱乐部的会歌（我待会儿会讲到），他还根据霍加斯的画作写了一部清唱剧，在干草市场剧院上演。
to an English-owned tavern, while a group of sort of ragged, half-skeletal, sinister-looking French soldiers and a very fat French Catholic friar look at this beef. It's sort of slavering, you know, with great envy. And this was turned into a best-selling print and renamed oh the roast beef of old england and one of his friends at the beefsteak club a guy called theodosius forest he'd written the club anthem of the beefsteak club which i'll come to you later and he wrote a cantata based on hogarth's painting which was performed at the haymarket
为了让你体会到这部清唱剧的敏感性，里面有一个法国士兵，被赋予了以下台词，它们是用一种蹩脚的英法夹杂语写成的。所以法国士兵说：“啊，神圣的上帝，去那里的yonder，看起来很诱人，红白相间，Bega，我看到了来自伦敦的牛肉，哦，求你让我咬一小口。”所以它基本上是用这种可怕的……然后他又做了一个……你看，大约10年后，霍加斯画了另一幅关于青蛙的画，叫做《入侵》。所以这是在七年战争期间，像往常一样存在入侵的恐惧。在这幅画中，是一群准备启程前往英国的法国人，他们在火上烤青蛙。这是一个小吃，巴尔韦德博士，非常像哥斯达黎加播客里的巴尔韦德博士。汤姆，我深信你曾答应为巴尔韦德博士的家人做一场慈善义演，因为你曾如此残忍地中伤过他们。一定要去听听那期播客，看看汤姆做了多么可耻的事。所以在《入侵》这幅画中，法国人在烤青蛙。这一次，
theater and to give you a sense of the sensitivity of the cantata, there's a French soldier who is given the following lines, and they are written in kind of cod franglais. So the French soldier says, Ah, sacre dieu, va-t'o ici yonder, That looks tempting, red and white, Bega, I see the roast beef from Londres, Oh, grant me one little bite. So it's literally written in this appalling um uh then he does another um you see he said about frogs hogart did another picture
霍加斯的另一个朋友和吃牛肉的伙伴，一个叫大卫·加里克的人，伟大的演员，他的剧院和俱乐部至今仍屹立在伦敦。他写了一段伴随的说明文字：“带着灯笼般的下巴和呱呱叫的肠子，看看那个半饥半饿的法国人……”剧院和俱乐部至今仍屹立在伦敦。他写了一段伴随的说明文字。
about 10 years later called the invasion so this is during the seven years war and there are as usual invasion fears and in that it's the group of french preparing to embark for england and they are roasting frogs over a fire it's a snack dr valverde very like dr valverde from the costa rican podcast for which tom you've i believe promised to do a charity benefit in in uh to benefit dr valverde's family having maligned them so cruelly. Do listen to that podcast if you want to find out what Tom did so disgracefully. So in the invasion, the French are roasting frogs. And this time,
“带着灯笼般的下巴和咕咕叫的肚子，看那半饥半饿的法国人耀武扬威，管我们叫英国狗。但很快我们将教训这些吹牛的敌人，牛肉和啤酒比汤和烤青蛙带来更沉重的打击。”所以这绝对是一件大事。而且我认为这里开始潜入了一种自我讽刺的成分。所以在18世纪60年代——所以我认为这类东西的巅峰时期大概是，我不知道，18世纪40、50年代。到了18世纪60年代，它在某种程度上变成了一种人们正在努力去模仿的漫画形象。
another of Hogarth's friends and sort of beefsteak eating chums, who's a guy called David Garrick, great actor, whose theatre and club still stand in London. He wrote an accompanying caption with lantern jaws and croaking gut. See how the half starved Frenchman theatre and club still stand in London. He wrote an accompanying caption.
所以汤姆，我知道你喜欢约翰逊和鲍斯韦尔。所以约翰逊博士，伟大的词典编纂家和评论家，詹姆斯·鲍斯韦尔，他的苏格兰传记作家。鲍斯韦尔于1762年来到伦敦。在12月，他刻意尽最大努力去践行这种形象，因为他在日记中写道：“英国人民的敌人，那些希望把他们描绘成最坏形象的人，把他们表现为自私、爱吃牛肉和残忍的。带着这种观点，我今天决心做一个根正苗红的老派英国人。我去了城里的帕特诺斯特罗城的多莉牛排馆，独自吞下了晚餐，以满足自私的指控。我吃了一块又大又肥的牛排，以满足吃牛肉的指控。然后我在五点钟去了圣詹姆斯公园的皇家斗鸡场，看了大约五个小时的斗鸡，以满足残忍的指控。”
With lantern jaws and croaking gut, see how the half-starved Frenchman strut and call us English dogs. But soon we'll teach these bragging foes that beef and beer give heavier blows than soup and roasted frogs. So this is very much a thing. And I think there's an element of self-parody beginning to creep in here. So by the 1760s, so the peak of this stuff, I would say, is probably, I don't know, 1740s, 50s. By the 1760s, it's slightly becoming a caricature that people
这真是非常英国式的行为。这确实是非常英国式的行为。但最让人震惊的是，实际上，现在当我读出来时才注意到，他看了五个小时的斗鸡。整整五个小时，是的。那可真是挺长……这几乎就像去看板球比赛了。五天。所以到了那个时候，它已经变成了一种人们正在刻意效仿的漫画形象，我认为。
are living up to. So Tom, I know you love Johnson and Boswell. So Dr. Johnson, the great lexicographer and critic, James Boswell, his Scottish biographer. Boswell came to London in 1762. And in December, he deliberately does his best to live up to this because he writes in his journal, the enemies of the people of England who would have them considered in the worst light represent them as selfish, beef eaters and cruel. In this view, I resolve today to be a true born old Englishman. I went to the city to Dolly's Steakhouse in Paternoster Row and I swallowed my dinner by myself to fulfill the charge of selfishness. I had a large fat beef steak to fulfill the charge of beef eating. And then I went at five o'clock to the Royal Cockpit in St. James's
正是在18世纪60年代，你得到了……所以首先，你得到了将英国人描绘成屠夫的漫画。你在版画中可以看到这一点。通常是一个屠夫带着他的斗牛犬或獒犬。这就像是一直追溯到《亨利五世》，那里谈到了獒犬。然后接替屠夫形象的是约翰·牛。所以约翰·牛是在1712年由另一位苏格兰作家约翰·阿思布思诺特创造的，原本是为了戏弄英国人。但他的形象在18世纪60年代到世纪末之间真正达到了巅峰，
Park and I saw cocking for about five hours to fulfil the charge of cruelty. That is very English behaviour. It is very English behaviour. But the staggering thing about that, actually, now that I only noticed it when I read it out, he watched the cockfighting for five hours. For five hours, yeah. That's a long... It's almost like going to cricket. Five days. So by that point, it's become a bit of a caricature, I think, that people are
特别是在法国大革命期间。他是一个胖子，正如你所说的，汤姆，他很健壮，穿着背心。他经常被描绘成手里拿着一大罐啤酒，吃着布丁或吃着牛排之类。他很直率、怀疑、反知识分子。是的，谢谢。那就是我。但实际上，约翰·牛的巅峰期真正到来，是在法国大革命期间，
living up to. It's in the 1760s that you get the... So first of all, you get the caricature of the Englishman as a butcher. You see this in Prince. So it'll be a butcher accompanied by his bulldog or his mastiff. It's like going back all the way to Henry V, talking mastiffs there. And then what takes over from the butcher is John Bull. So John Bull had been created in 1712 by, again, a Scottish writer actually called John Arthbuthnot, kind of teasing the English. But he really peaks between 1760s and the end of the century,
当时他与瘦弱、狂热、理想主义、残酷、理性主义、无神论者的雅各宾派形成了鲜明对照。你还记得爱丁堡那个非常非常著名的引语吗，关于大都市、喋喋不休阶层的？没错，是的，因为“蕨类植物底下的半打蚂蚱，用它们那急切的鸣叫声让整个田野嗡嗡作响，而数千头高大的牛则安歇在英国橡树的阴凉处，反刍着草料，保持着沉默。请千万不要以为那些制造噪音的人就是田野里唯一的居民。”你看，这就是对整个主题的一种重新校准，对吧？
especially during the French Revolution. He's a fat man, as you said, Tom, he's stout, he's in his waistcoat. He's often shown with a tankard of beer in his hand, eating a pudding or eating a beefsteak or something like this. He's bluff, he's sceptical, he's anti-intellectual. Yeah, thanks. He's me. But actually, you get the peak of John Bull, and that's really during the French Revolution
绝对是的。但约翰·牛可以说是这种文化的最后盛开，因为到那个时候，牛肉这套东西已经变得有点……不仅是个笑话，而且成了昨日黄花。所以我觉得随着1815年法国大革命战争的结束、拿破仑战争的结束，关于牛肉和自由的一切，那些人现在都已经去世了。
when he is juxtaposed with skinny, enthusiastic, idealistic, cruel, rationalist, atheistical kind of Jacobins. And you get the very, very famous quote from Edinburgh, don't you, about the metropolitan, the chattering classes that's right yeah because half a dozen grasshoppers under a fern make the field ring with their importunate chink while thousands of great cattle reposed beneath the shadow of the british oak chew the card and are silent pray do not imagine that those who make the noise are the only inhabitants of the field there you go that's a kind of recalibration of the whole theme, isn't it?
霍加斯、加里克、所有这些人物、约翰逊博士，绝对都成了昨日黄花。工业革命意味着英国正变得越来越城市化。因此，对乡村田园的这种召唤——我是说，现在实际上在维多利亚时期，当乡村乡绅之类的人物出现在小说和流行文化中时，他们已经不再是国家的灵魂。
It is, absolutely. But John Bourne is kind of the last flowering of this because by that point, the kind of beef stuff has become a little bit, it's not just that it's a joke, it's become yesterday's theme. So I think that with the end of the French Revolutionary Wars, with the end of the Napoleonic Wars in 1815, then all the stuff about beef and liberty, all those people are dead now.
他们只是可笑的落后人物，正被铁路、实业家和商人们所取代。死锁勋爵。完全正确。是的，实际上，完全是这样。《荒凉山庄》里的雷克斯·死锁简直完美。你看一个在100年前会被称为西部乡绅的人物，对吧？有点像《汤姆·琼斯》里的那种人，而现在到处都在下雨，凄凉无比，死锁急急忙忙赶往伦敦，是的，完全正确……
Hogarth, Garrick, all those characters, Dr. Johnson, they are absolutely yesterday's news. The Industrial Revolution means that Britain is becoming much more urban. So the invocation of the kind of rural, I mean, now actually in the Victorian period when rural squires and stuff appear in fiction and popular culture, they are not the soul of the nation.
但同样是因为滑铁卢战役之后，法国的威胁在某种程度上已经消失了，你知道，残存的某种表演式的反法情绪还是有的，我想，但大体上，你知道，那场战斗已经赢了。因此，法国入侵的威胁、吃青蛙的威胁，以及人们对那些可疑的食材和调料的担忧都已经减弱了。老英格兰的烤牛肉之类的事情让人感觉只是过时了。但我认为它得以存续的地方……它确实还稍微延续了一点。如果你知道那家连锁餐厅的话，它依然存在。我是说，鉴于你的倾向，汤姆，你最好还是别去光顾。
They are just ludicrous backward figures who are being superseded by railways and industrialists and businessmen. Lord Deadlock. Exactly. Yes, actually, that's exactly right. Celeste Deadlock in Bleak House is perfect. See somebody who 100 years earlier would have been squire western wouldn't he yeah and kind of tom jones and now it's always raining and miserable and exactly deadlock goes
伦敦的霍克斯莫尔餐厅。没有。你从来没去过霍克斯莫尔？没有。那是极好的餐厅。只有几家。它们基本上专营牛排。它们的标志就是“牛肉与自由”。
rushing off to london yeah yeah exactly right um but also because the french threat has kind of gone with the aftermath of waterloo you know there's there is a there's a degree of sort of performative anti-frenchness left i suppose but by and large you know, there's a degree of sort of performative anti-Frenchness left, I suppose. But by and large, you know, that battle is won. And so the threat of French invasion and of frog eating or whatever, and of people sort of dodgy stocks and sources has abated. And the sort of roast beef of old England stuff just feels old fashioned. But where I think it, so it does live on a little bit. It lives on, if you, do you know the restaurant chain? I mean, you'd be ill advised to visit it, Tom, given your proclivities.
所以它们重现了——它们除了牛肉还供应别的吗？是的，它们供应海鲜。它们供应多佛鳎鱼。它们可能会做酿蘑菇之类的东西，汤姆。我认为这个文化得以存续的另一个地方——现在你可以告诉我，你觉得这完全是胡扯还是疯狂。显然，本·罗杰斯把近代早期的人称为近代早期世界的德克萨斯人。
Hawksmoor in London. No. You've never been to a Hawksmoor? No. They're excellent restaurants. There's only a few of them. They are, they're basically specialised in steaks. And their logo is Beef and Liberty.
美国确实有那种感觉，对吧？像德克萨斯人拿着他们巨大的牛排。我想这可能是一点衍生，因为这也与那种非常美国化、非常爱国、非常大男子主义、热血的形象联系在一起。我要在德克萨斯牛排馆里吃一块巨大的牛排。我想这其中是不是也有那么一点点食物被赋予了政治含义的意思。我是说，我来告诉你一个完美体现这种精神的人，那就是伊恩·博瑟姆，他的外号就叫“牛肉饼（Beefy）”。是的，绝对是的。
So they reproduce the- Do they serve anything else apart from beef? Yeah, they serve seafood. They serve Dover sole. They might do stuffed mushrooms or something, Tom. The other places where I think this lives on, now you can tell me whether you think this is completely spurious and mad. Obviously, Ben Rogers called the early modern the texans of the early modern world
而且他简直是一个典型的约翰·牛式的人物。是的，绝对是这样。所以伊恩·博瑟姆是一位英国板球运动员，在80年代可能是世界上最著名的板球运动员，对于我们的美国和不看板球的听众来说——是的，澳大利亚人不会立刻认出他，并且听到提到博瑟姆勋爵、博瑟姆勋爵时会高兴得大笑——现在的牛肉勋爵博瑟姆、脱欧勋爵博瑟姆，我想人们是这么叫他的，对吧？因为他非常直言不讳。人们有时确实会叫他牛肉博瑟姆。他们会的，绝对会。好吧，我在我的书里写过这个，关于80年代初期的书《谁敢赢》，当时让我印象深刻的是，博瑟姆是如此一个18世纪式的人物，痛击外国人、吃牛肉、行为有些出格，体重稍微有点问题，所有这些特征。所以博瑟姆击败澳大利亚人，种族是我想问的另一件事。现在，你肯定会说这完全是胡扯，看看澳大利亚人对待烧烤的方式中是否有一点点这种联系。他们对待烧烤相当热血。那是一件很男人的事。喝杯啤酒，搞个烧烤。并不花哨。其中有一种简单和真实。不，因为我觉得那更多与狩猎有关。狩猎，对吧？
there is a definite sense isn't there in america like text the idea of the texan with his massive stake i wonder if that's a slight derivation because that's also associated with it's very american very patriotic very kind of macho manly red, red-blooded. I'm going to have a massive steak in a Texan steakhouse. I wonder whether there's a slight element there of the food having, the sort of meat-eating having a kind of political meaning. I mean, I'll tell you somebody who is the embodiment of this spirit is Ian Botham, whose nickname is Beefy. Yeah, absolutely.
难道不是吗？那是那种——我不知道。我从来没去过澳大利亚，所以我不知道。也许吧。我不知道。我不会认为这是直接传承自那个传统。好吧。嗯，我并不认为这是直接的，我只是在想——因为我认为关于食物最迷人的一点是，有些人会说，哦，这……有时候当我们偏离政治和战争时，有些人会说，哦，这不算真正的历史。但实际上，我认为像食物、文化、习俗这样的东西，是了解一个社会思考方式的绝佳窗口。
And he's kind of a paradigmatic John Bull figure. He is, absolutely so ian botham is a english cricketer who was probably the most famous cricketer in the world in the 80s for our american and non-cricket playing yes australians will not have recognized him immediately and be laughing with joy at the mention of serene both more lord botham lord botham now lord botham of beef lord botham of brexit i think people call it don't they because he's a very outspoken they sometimes call him lord both of beef they do they do absolutely well i wrote about this in um and he did who dares wins my book about the early 80s and i i struck me at the time both them is
显然现在在英国，汤姆，我们真的和那种“牛肉与自由”的精神失去联系了，不是吗？你觉得那些日子还会重现吗？嗯，正如我们在开始时所说的那样，我认为疯牛病象征着英格兰国体中有些东西已经腐烂了，因为人们对作为英格兰象征的牛肉的民间记忆依然存在。是的。这就是为什么那些……
such a kind of 18th century figure smiting foreigners eating eating beef, behaving badly, slightly issues with his weight, all of that sort of stuff. So both in beating Australians, race is the other thing I was going to ask about. Now, you will, I'm sure, say this is completely spurious, whether there is a tiny hint of an association. So the way that Australians think about their barbecues, they're quite kind of red-blooded. It's a manly thing to do. You had a beer, have a barbecue. It's not fancy. There's a simplicity and a sort of authenticity to it. No, because I think that's more to do with hunting. Hunting, right.
你知道的，那些奶牛基本上被喂食成食人动物然后发疯的景象，会成为如此有力的隐喻。是的，确实是的。
Isn't it? It's the idea of the- I don't know. I've never been to Australia, so I don't know. Maybe. I don't know. I wouldn't have thought it's a direct line of descent from that. Okay. Well, I didn't think it was direct, but I was just wondering whether... Because I think one of the fascinating things about food, some people will say, oh, this is... Sometimes when we veer off from politics and wars, some people say, oh, this isn't proper history. But actually, I think things like food, culture, customers, they're wonderful windows into how a society thinks.
令人沮丧的隐喻。好吧，这实际上正是灵感来源。所以我提到了本·罗杰斯那本精彩的书。我再提一次，因为我从里面抄袭了太多东西。《牛肉与自由》。他说这就是启发他写这本书的原因，对疯牛病的反应。
And obviously now in Britain, Tom, we really have lost touch with that beef and liberty, haven't we? Do you think those days will ever return? Well, as we said at the beginning, I think the mad cow disease was emblematic of something being rotten in the state of England because the folk memory of beef as an emblem of England did remain. Yeah. Which is why the site,
所以，汤姆，我觉得我们应该以一个乐观的基调结束。我是说，尽管我们知道——我们录音时并不知道，也不知道英格兰是否已经在世界杯中出局了。他们开局不错。我们只看了一场比赛，对吧？所以我不知道我们提到那场比赛现在听起来会带有一种凄美讽刺的意味，还是那是通往辉煌之路的第一步。
the site of, you know, the thought of cows basically being fed, being made into cannibals and then going mad was such a kind of potent metaphor. Yeah. Yeah, it was.
没有人知道。但我认为我们应该以崇高牛肉俱乐部的会歌来结束。我不会唱的。你们会很高兴听到这一点的。如果你想听音乐，去听乌拉圭播客和优美的图帕马罗斯主题曲。或者突尼斯的那首。
Depressing metaphor. Well, that was actually what inspired. So I mentioned Ben Roch's brilliant book. I'll mention it again because I've stolen so much from it. Beef and Liberty. He says that's what inspired him to write the book, was the reaction to mad cow disease.
是的，为了汤姆的歌剧。是的。但这是崇高牛肉俱乐部的会歌：“荣耀不再展翅为英雄、国家和翅膀歌唱，女神走向更崇高的飞翔，赞美我们英国的牛肉牛排，这是自由的不列颠的欢乐主题，因牛肉和自由而幸福。在专制者统治的整个国度，如今还剩下什么荣耀的痕迹？他们的人民，权力和骄傲的奴隶，被剥夺了肥美的牛肉和自由。哪个国度、哪个国家能感到幸福，渴望着我们的牛肉和自由？”
So, Tom, I think we should end on an upbeat note. I mean, for all we know, so we don't know when we're recording this and we don't know whether England have crashed out of the World Cup. They've begun well. We've only seen one match, haven't we? So I don't know whether us mentioning that match will now have a poignantly ironic ring or whether that was the first step on the road to glory.
再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。如需收听独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。
Nobody knows. But I think we shall end with the anthem of the sublime society of beefsteaks. I won't sing it. You'll be pleased to hear. If you want music, go to the Uruguay podcast and the beautiful Tupamaros theme. Or indeed the Tunisian one.
没人知道。但我认为我们应该以崇高牛排协会的会歌来结束。我不会唱的。你们听了一定很高兴。如果你想要音乐，去听乌拉圭播客和优美的图帕马罗。或者突尼斯的也可以。
Yeah, for Tom's opera. Yeah. But this is the Sublime Society of Beefsteaks, their club song. No more shall fame expand her wings to sound of heroes, states and wings, a nobler flight the goddess takes to praise our British beef in steaks, a joyful theme for Britain's free, happy in beef and liberty. Throughout the realm where despots reign, what tracks of glory now remain? Their people, slaves of power and pride, fat beef and freedom are denied. What realm, what state can happy be, wanting our beef and liberty?
是的，为了汤姆的歌剧。是的。但这是崇高牛排协会的会歌，他们的俱乐部歌曲。名誉之翼不再展开，为英雄、政要和飞翼奏鸣，女神展开更崇高的飞翔，歌颂我们英国的牛肉牛排，这是英国自由之民的欢乐主题，在牛肉与自由中快乐。在暴君统治的王国里，如今还留下什么荣耀的足迹？他们的人民，权力和傲慢的奴隶，被剥夺了肥美的牛肉和自由。有什么王国、什么国家能快乐，却渴望我们的牛肉和自由？
Goodbye. Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的剩余部分》。想要获取额外单集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。